[Music]  captain's log 53 days and still no sign  of finally I see we'd made it Ducker  here  welcome to California's majestic kelp  forest the redwoods of the ocean  [Music]  kelp is one of the fastest growing  plants on earth some species can grow up  to 24 inches per day giant kelp like the  ones around us can reach upwards of 200  feet that's taller than the Leaning  Tower of Pisa  exactly kelp force thrive in cool  coastal waters and are home to hundreds  of different types of animals like seals  sea lions lobster fish sea otters  virgins even octopi more than just cold  water  kelp likes turbulence thanks these  turbulent waters are constantly stirring  up nutrients the kelp needs to survive  unfortunately these forests off Catalina  are suffering from the effects of  climate change and warming ocean  temperatures beautiful isn't it  I have an idea gather round everyone  let's take it Kofi get it they don't  [Music]